welcome back to the show quick thank you
to today's new member of the day Richard
Steiger Richard thank you really
appreciate your support I encourage you
to join Richard @ww join pakman.com
support media that you believe is
valuable I also want to say thanks to
Kathryn Dickson who's today's longtime
sustaining member of the day she's been
with us for almost five years really
really inspiring to see people support
us for so long through I mean the show
was much smaller when Kathryn started
supporting us and now we are a whole
different thing if you want to get a
really great membership discount on my
birthday on February 2nd simply get on
our mailing list at david pakman.com and
then on February 2nd you will get a very
very special email with a secret process
by which you can get a david pakman show
member at a very discounted rate ok
let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 why don't we start with our caller
from the 203 area code 203 who's there I
was just tired from your aging hey go
ahead and it's kind of a simple question
but it's kind of hard to answer it as
I'm asking you maybe if you can give me
a response with some kind of brevity
would be helpful I think basically you
know like in all of our lives I'm kind
of like a Marxist I care about a lot of
things follow politics for a long time
now and like world events and basically
there's a lot of people who just don't
really understand like why they don't
have any sort of structural view of like
why you might be interested in why
certain things happen and I just have a
lot of like apolitical people just want
to like live their lives free of
thinking of anything you know beyond
their immediate and so you know if
someone says they you know to to you you
know why do you follow this stuff or
whatever you know they're kind of any
response you can get to them yeah what I
would usually say to people who say I'm
just not into politics is I will say
what matters to you and invariably
unless they're really apathetic about
everything in which case I would start
to wonder whether they're maybe
depressed and should be seeking mental
health help something probably matters
to them and whatever it is relates to
politics right people will say you know
I'm just really wrapped up in what
matters to me is raising my kids
for example that's that's really what I
care about just my kids doing everything
I can for my kids that relates to
politics right education health care the
world we live in climate change all of
these things relate to what kind of a
world are your kids going to live in so
I would probably take a sort of gentle
questioning approach and say oh that's
interesting
what does matter to you and starting to
show them that that is connected to the
decisions that we make about who
represents us okay thank you all right
thank you